a show were forced to break up a protest
outside a state bank in the city of
mandalay around
a thousand people at a peaceful rally
were dispersed with rubber bullets and
slingshots
more than 10 truckloads of security
forces and police were deployed to the
scene
where demonstrators were calling for
myanmar's military leaders to reinstate
their elected government
extra troops were also sent to other
parts of the country
in myanmar's largest city yangon
soldiers in armored vehicles and tanks
patrolled the streets
one group of the civil disobedience
movements cdm for short
stood in front of the central bank in
yangon and continued with their calls
for the military government to step down
and the country's democratically elected
leaders to be released
we are protesting peacefully without
weapons and with no intention of
violence
to call for cdm and fight for the
freedom of government staff
this as the military issued a statement
on its facebook page
outlining the possible punishment for
protesters
saying any act spoken or written that
expresses or incites hatred of the
government could lead to 20 years in
prison
people gathered outside a court in the
capital nepado hoping that the deposed
civilian leader aung sang-soo-chi
would be released on monday but that did
not happen
according to the remand which was set
today is the last day of the remand
period
but from the discussions with the
district justice the remain period is
now until the 17th
not today tsuchi was one of the first to
be detained in the early hours of the
coup
two weeks ago she's been charged with
illegally
importing six walkie-talkie radios
according to a monitoring group
more than 400 people have now been
detained since the february first
coup there's a vast range of people
within that group
and that's of real concern for 23 year
old fortune teller charlotte a fellow
yangon fortune teller was arrested a few
days ago
after a video of him praying for the
military to fail
went viral
since they're dictators they can make up
whatever laws they like to oppress us
we astrologers are like birds in their
hands if they squeeze we are dead
if they let us fly we are free this is
the nature of dictatorship
and it's not just happening to us it's
everyone and that's probably why
protesters are still coming out in
strength
the ruling national league for democracy
nld party
won by a landslide in last november's
election and was popular
most see this move by the military as
nullification of their
vote and their voice devigo palin al
jazeera